the juror experience the problem is it's
so delicious
well that's you know and those keto
desserts are mostly [ __ ]
[ __ ] honestly no it i i just have to
roll my eyes
the paleo treats and the keto desserts
and the you know all these things are
like trying to
come up with a version it's almost like
you know beyond meat trying to come up
with a piece of steak that's made out of
you know of vegetables and and here we
are trying to
create a a sugary dessert that looks
like a dessert and tastes like a dessert
but it's made with erythritol and
alliance and all this other stuff i'm
glad you brought that up because
i think there's real promise in these uh
these meats that are made in a
laboratory in terms of their cloning
meat
you know they're taking meat and
reproducing it and i've seen some of
these
really strange looking 3d printed steaks
but it's actual animal tissue
but these meat substitutes that are made
with seed oils
yeah just horrible just horrible
knowing that there is a study and we've
talked about it on the podcast where
they fed rats these
these things and they had horrible
[ __ ] rats eat each other they eat
everything yeah they garbage yeah
they're fine
yep they got those they eat those fake
burgers and they're sick as [ __ ]
i know they started getting liver
problems yep yeah i
i i can't explain it um it's amazing how
many people think that those things are
good for you beyond
oh beyond amazing um yeah it's
impossible oh wait
no it's uh it's just
it's just nuts it's just nuts that that
that
again that the collective conscience of
the country
would rally around something so inane
so so antithetical to health and
in the name of saving the climate or
saving the animals or whatever
there's never going to be any well not
in our lifetime even the cell
you know the matrix lab-grown meat the
cell cell-based stuff
still lacks a lot of the nutrients you
know you have to have the infusion of
the capillaries and all of the stuff you
have
a real animal to get the full impact of
all this they need to clone headless
animals
with no souls yeah exactly that's what
they need to do i mean
then they would have to exercise in
order to be like really delicious
that's the thing like the difference
between a wild game animal and an animal
that's stuck in a pen like veal
yeah which is disgusting a wild game
animal is rich and
red and dark and it's it's denser it's
more chewy
right because it's a it's a denser
healthy and you think you're going to
get that from a lab grown
no no so you know we're back to you've
got a headless elf
okay i mean it's steroids and you have
running on a treadmill
let's patent that jamie right make a
note um
yeah it's i think you know regenerative
agriculture is
is the way we need to go to feed the
world
uh not through ceasing
growing animals and trying to do it all
in the lab i think well rob wolf has a
new book out he was supposed to be on
um right around april but a bunch of
[ __ ] went down and
we're going to have them on again uh but
his bull
his book is about that his book is all
about
the benefits of regenerative agriculture
yeah the people that are skeptical
though don't think that we could do it
at a scale that's necessary to provide
as many people with meat as
eat meat in this country because of fast
food production
fast food production the way they
believe the way i've heard it argued it
makes a lot of sense
is that the scale in which we're
consuming
meat in this country because of fast
food
requires factory farming to keep up with
it
well for now it does but you know
there's a there's got to be a tipping
point there's got to be a point at which
we have to recognize that by by
concentrating
everything in our world not just food
but all of these different
concentrations
that there's a point at which we can't
satisfy
people's needs and and and and
so i i see us sort of going back to the
cottage industry farm the local grown
you know the local farmers i mean i
would love to see if there's going to be
any subsidies in agriculture it should
be for
for locals for local small farms that
are trying to do regenerative
agriculture
and reclaim the topsoil and and you know
build back
instead of continuously depleting it
yeah i think so too and i think
one of the interesting things is that
one of the big arguments
against everyone eating vegetables is
model crop agriculture which is
essentially what you would need
this is the real problem it becomes a
conundrum because everyone i think
everyone with a moral with a heart and a
soul agrees that factory farming in
terms of animals is disgusting
it's horrible but i don't think they
understand the horrors of monocrop
agriculture and how bad it is it's so
bad
for the environment it's so bad for the
soil
it's bad for the animals it's it's
terrible for all the wildlife that gets
moved and and displaced because of the
fact that you have
you know 4 000 acres of corn or some
crazy [ __ ] like that
and when they turn that corn up with a
combine
a lot of [ __ ] dies there is no way
you're going to go out there and hand
pick 4 000 acres of corn you're not
going to do it right you use machinery
and during that machinery it's
indiscriminate it chews up everything
not only that you have to use some sort
of pesticides
you have to use something that
discourages predation you have to use
all these different methods
to keep animals like if you have 4 000
acres of corn you're going to have
a food source where animals are going to
swarm in
and eat all of your crops that's what
they would do if that was a it was
a normal thing that occurred in the wild
if in the wild all of a sudden out of
nowhere there was
4 000 acres of naturally growing
vegetables
that would be one of the most wildlife
rich areas 100
100 yeah so how do they keep that from
happening well they do with poison
they do they discourage it with with
pesticides
with all sorts of different methods of
eliminating insects if you care about
insects
they destroy insect populations insects
which are also
critical to the growth of the soil it's
like there's this natural cycle so then
they have to add a bunch of nitrogen and
[ __ ]
to the soil and they estimate that we
have like i think the
latest estimation jamie look this up the
united states farmlands have
i believe 60 more
seasons i heard 50 but yeah it's a
number yeah it's
which is it's a dwindling number it's a
diminishing number until
all of the nutrients are depleted you
and me might be dead but jamie's going
to ride this out
jamie's going to be here at the end of
crops he's going to be in this bunker
with his
lab-grown meat yeah i'll be uh 113
hooked up to an iv nad machine and and
jamie will be uh
he'll be out there trucking eating lab
grown carrots
i just don't understand why people don't
recognize that
both these things are terrible factory
farming is terrible
and this mono crop agriculture and this
is the argument they always use
we need these model crop agriculture
things to feed animals
well no we don't what you need is
natural grasslands which is what these
when you saw when the the settlers saw
millions of bison running across the the
plains
what were they eating were they eating
mono crop gmo soy
no they weren't they were eating grass
that's what they're supposed to eat
and when they do that they [ __ ] on the
ground that
[ __ ] fertilizes the grasses and
fertilizes all the other plants
and then you have this whole ecosystem
of animals that exist within these
within these fields and it's supposed to
be that way they're supposed to coexist
together
and they work together symbiotically to
make sure that and
you can do that at least we've we've
demonstrated on small scale
and this is what rob's book is about and
a lot of other people have talked about
this as well
that when it's done correctly it
actually produces a carbon neutral
effect yeah
nature always has the best answer catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience